You've seen a lot of different parts of
user experience for specific products.
Now I'd like you to find a relatively
new product and try it out and
document all of your thoughts
about the user experience.
This can be anything from the home page,
to emails, to checkout,
to interactions on the site.
You want to build an eye for
amazing products, and
the best way to do that is to see
how others have done it in the past.
So, write a post that describes
the tasks you attempt in the product,
how the product did and did not help
you, how you felt along the way, and
any design elements you feel
contributed to your experience.
Once you've written your post and
shared it on the discussions,
check this box to continue.